these two know each other from the
rebuilding efforts after the tsunami
Mohammed nordine is the mayor of swanee
mama Anatoly Jaya is the head of the
rebuilding project mayor nordeen shows
us how agriculture is flourishing in his
community he's proud of the local
produce like mangoes papaya coffee
rubber and cocoa project leader maman is
pleased that people are providing for
themselves two years or five years first
after tsunami they must be depending on
the help under other sub organization as
Angie who because as you know that in
sewanee special is the totally damaged
by tsunami the spot where these chickens
now Rome was hit by the wave in 2004 the
whole area was flooded within seconds
muhammad nadeem lost his wife as well as
three children
his village swanee lies in the arts a
region on the west coast of Sumatra it
was swallowed up by the sea with only
rubble remaining Indonesia was the
worst-hit country with a hundred and
seventy thousand people killed houses
were swept away and much of the country
was underwater rice fields and
plantations were destroyed by the
disaster
no people are growing crops again though
and widows and widowers are remarrying
but family life is still hard yeah any
gum was a good to eat once I had enough
money to send all of my children to
school but not anymore Lou Lou gaw
Monica Pier mom when you call that guy
named Ananias here who done got it no
it's just enough to live on the louisa
below the level in the village planted
new natural rubber plantations with
money from the government and aid
organizations the first drops of rubber
are already trickling out of the trees
it'll be another year before the rubber
can be harvested my mom knows the
farmers have to be patient this
presentation is a long term of for the
in continuation for demo because the
rubber plantation is have a long edge
like 30 years
the two men head over to one of the most
important places in the village the new
mosque
the prayer room is almost finished it's
not just a religious Center in the
devout region of OJ it's also a place of
work for local craftsmen Marga you give
ya ten people from the village work here
gavin ii project leader maman is happy
with the work that goes on and he's
always good for a joke as well even
though things are improving for most
people here they're still plagued by one
problem in particular the tsunami ruined
their crop fields maybe gallon a porno
me the economy is going well many of us
are even driving motorbikes data bank
but on the other hand we have to buy
rice our staple food source so the
tsunami destroyed the rice fields yeah
and now we can't grow anything they're
the ones arable land is now rough
terrain the salt water flooded areas
that used to be rice fields can only be
crossed on rickety wooden boards no
crops will grow here now at best cattle
can graze here Saudi
mamon says rice will never grow here
again so how would the village protect
itself in the event of another tsunami
the answer is by using trees as a
barricade the government has planted
trees right on the beach they grow
quickly and their strong roots should
help to protect the village from another
wave
the trees are like find give advice this
is a good for the acid for the
anticipate some disaster awesome tsunami
because the root for the tree is a very
very very good for the line the trees
will provide protection but the
villagers still have to be prepared ya
got the experience I think we're well
prepared hopefully next time the warning
will come in time get the pool area yeah
an early warning system has been placed
in the sea but no one here is certain
the alarm will reach remote areas before
it's too late
you